علماء النفس والادراك الذين درسوا تاريخ
الشتائم يشيرون الى انها ظهرت منذ ايام
رجل الكهف الاول واصبحت النساء تميل الان
الى الشتائم بنفس القدر مع الرجال واحيانا
اكثر منهم يكشف تقرير الخبير الشهير في
الالفاظ النابيه واستاذ علم النفس يتم في
ان الكلمات البذيئه مفيده في مجمل
السيناريوهات على سبيل المثال تحمل المزيد
من الالم فقد اظهر المتطوعون الذين وضعوا
ايديهم في الثلج اظهروا قدره اكبر على
التحمل عندما اطلقوا الشتائم في التجربه
كذلك تزيد القوه البدنيه باستخدام
البداءات في تجربه اجريت عام 2018 اكتشف
باحثون ان قوه قبضه اليد كانت اكبر بين
المشاركين الذين كرروا الشتائم بل يجد
العلم ايضا ان الاشخاص الذين يشتمون اكثر
جداره بالثقه وكانوا اكثر صدقا واقل خداعا
بالطبع السب هو وسيله مساعده مهمه لتجنب
الاشتباك الجسدي المباشر فهو وسيله
للتنفيس عن المشاعر عمليا وجدت الدراسه ان
الاشخاص الاقدر على صياغه شتائم جديده
اكثر قدره على انشاء كلمات وجمل بشكل
منتظم ايضا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات